Metal Gear Solid creator Hideo Kojima
took to the stage at Jeff Keeley's
Gamescom press conference to reveal more
new footage of death stranding while the
story information we got was still vague
we're slowly getting more details about
the way it plays here's an analysis of
the most interesting details from the
new footage as you explore the world it
seems you can rest and take a nap it
looks like this is done to facilitate
regenerating the health of both Sam and
his BB with all the beautiful sights
we've seen thus far this seems like a
nice feature you can use to relax after
the game's more tense encounters just a
little longer
in past trailers the arm on the back of
Sam's suit was used to detect BTS which
are the deadly invisible creatures seen
in previous footage however it does have
other functions in the footage here you
can use the arm to scan the terrain and
locate points of interest in the world
[Music]
the latter is what Sam uses to reach
far-off locations based on previous
trailers it could be extended upwards
and even be used as a bridge it's not so
mind-boggling but the new gameplay shows
that the ladder can extend quite high
meaning that it seems capable of readily
adapting to whatever you're climbing
needs might be despite how long it
reached the ladder might have a limit of
how far it can extend and may demand
that you use it multiple times to reach
the tallest locations
one of the significant objectives of
death stranding is to deliver cargo and
establish connections with the other
inhabitants of the world in the gameplay
Sam came across what's called a you see
a delivery terminal which is a tiny
haven you can visit to drop off cargo
and ultimately establish strands with
characters and organizations according
to Kojima not all the people you deliver
cargo to are involved in the main story
and are more commonly relegated to the
games side activities however he advised
that you'll want to connect with them
anyway since doing so will provide you
with unique rewards and services the
delivery terminal menu also had a few
interesting options that could allude to
some of the activities you'll be doing
in deaths stranding there are options
for claiming materials recycling and
fabricating equipment which could mean
you might be spending time scavenging in
the world for resources and crafting
another interesting call-out was when
Sam initiated finishing a delivery the
successful job was estimated to grant
you a total of thirty likes it's
possible that these likes serve as
currency to your ability to establish
connections with others but how it all
works is still beyond us
like a real baby Sam's BB is sensitive
to the things happening in the
environment
if you accidentally fall a great
distance or suffer considerable damage
the BB will start crying to stop its
weeping you'll need to detach the BB
from Sam's suit and rock the baby into a
relaxed state via the ps4 controllers
motion sensor Kojima noted that your bb
could be affected in more severe ways
and even become poisoned if you're not
careful it's still unclear how the bb's
mood will impact gameplay or how far
you'll need to go to comfort it
regardless you'll need to be extra
careful
previously we've seen Sam pull from a
variety of tools and in equipment wheels
such as a ladder and a rope to help him
explore the environment however there's
a unique tool in Sam's Arsenal the
ability to urinate yes you're not drunk
you heard that correctly
it seems that Sam's bladder will fill up
over time as you can see from the
heads-up display indicating the number
of milliliters of urine in his bladder
according to kojima urination can be a
tool against enemies though the
specifics of how remains unclear after
Sam finished peeing a weird mushroom
sprouted from the ground
Kojima noted that death strandings world
is connected so if more players urinate
on that spot then the mushroom will grow
fully and become a useful consumable you
can pick up and that's everything we
noticed if you saw anything else super
cool or fishy be sure to let us know in
the comments below thanks for stranding
I mean what
My Luck